it's really exciting to be here I'm
humbled by all of the accomplishments of
the Nobel laureate and I'm also excited
to talk to you a little bit about the
future of intelligence from the lens of
expertise which is how people apply
their skill and knowledge to solve
problems in particular fields as I stand
before you today I'm reminded of the
first serious computer program I wrote
back in the mid-80s it was what we call
an expert system it was to help my dad
who was a judge in India to solve
automotive compensation cases I remember
that day vividly because we demonstrated
it to a colleague of my dad who went on
to become the supreme court chief
justice in India back then we imagined
and we dreamt that expertise could be
captured in computing systems but we
very quickly ran into a lot of
limitations these systems were fragile
they were not very usable and we could
not actually achieve those goals back
then but today we have so much data we
have so many new technologies we have so
much computing infrastructure that we
can make those dreams come to come true
I think we've reached a point where the
nature of expertise itself can be
changed this is a new era to put it very
simply experts of the future will
routinely work with learning and
reasoning machines to do their
day-to-day tasks in a very deep
collaborative relationship between
people and machines and this is nothing
to be fearful of it is an evolution as
we heard earlier today and I think that
it is going to be much better for the
world for all experts to be able to
leverage these learning and reasoning
machines I begin a set of demonstrations
to you by asking a very simple question
what is the price of not knowing today
we pay a lot because we don't know how
to manage the environment we pay a big
price for not knowing how to educate our
citizens and we pay a big price because
we don't know what's wrong with our
patients and the reason we're not able
to answer these very important questions
is because there's a huge amount of data
there's a lot of complexity around us as
you already heard today in fact there's
something like 2.5 exabytes of data
that's created every day and more than
90% of the data was created in the last
two years it's growing exponentially as
you heard before and even the
information that is curated like for
example in scientific journals and all
of the articles and analyst reports that
is doubling that's also on an
exponential curve imagine if we could
actually pull out the insights from this
complexity instead of being overwhelmed
we are able to work in partnership with
these learning and reasoning machines
that can help us pull these insights and
apply them in real time to the problems
that all of us knowledge workers do
every day that's what we call cognitive
computing
in IBM the brand for cognitive computing
is called Watson and we got the first
glimpse of this machine that we call
Watson when we demonstrated in an
exhibition match on Jeopardy which
already heard before the machine was
able to get information from a wide
variety of data sources even the messy
information that all of us people create
an answer open domain questions like
jeopardy in a very convincing way the
complexity of language is very high and
getting to understand the complexity of
language is already a big step forward
for machines let's take a quick look at
how the machine did and as you look at
this video please watch how Watson does
with a little panel at the bottom of the
screen a 15-ounce vo5 moisture milks
conditioner from this manufacturer
averages a buck online Ken Alberto yes
also on your computer keys for it's an
abbreviation for Grom free auto racing
Brandon what is f1 good computer Keys
4000 an additional section placed within
the folds of a newspaper Brett what is
tab no ken insert insert is right let's
go to 600 please vedic dating back at
least 4000 years is the earliest dialect
of this classical language of India
Watson what is Sanskrit Sanskrit is
correct and that takes you to 4200 as
you can see the machine is very good not
only at getting all the facts right but
also in understanding the nuances of
language Watson went on to win this
match and Rhea talked about one of the
more complex puns that Watson got right
I want to mention two things about this
demonstration the first point as you saw
at the bottom of the screen was that
Watson knew what it did not know it was
applying levels of confidence as it
found information matched them
statistically and tried to decide
whether or not to press the buzzer in
some cases it did not know and it did
not press the buzzer
the second even more important point is
that we built this machine not to be
autonomous or in some kind of a super
intelligent machine but rather we built
this machine to understand us humans and
how to work with us humans and what our
world looks like that was a
demonstration of a quiz game but we can
now see a future in which we can ask
computers like Watson the big questions
what is the root cause of cancer why are
there so few women in the field of
science can we actually reverse global
warming now these questions are much
more complicated and it requires
research and it requires deep
understanding of the domain and in order
to answer these questions you require we
require many dimensions of intelligence
machines don't have all of those
dimensions of intelligence in fact it is
a combination of people and machines
that can solve these big questions
humans are very good at self-directed
goals you heard earlier today about
bearing down humans are very good at
common sense lots of information that's
not digitized humans are great at value
judgments but what it means to live in
our world but machines on the other hand
are great at large scale mathematics at
discovering patterns in huge amounts of
data
and even extracting knowledge and
insights from huge amounts of data and
of course doing statistical reasoning
but even more importantly machines have
to understand domains very deeply if you
look at how many of the AI systems are
built today some of them are built for
personal personal assistant question
answering type applications some of them
are built for shopping some of them are
built for facial recognition and so
forth but we have taken a very different
approach in addition to building these
applications we have a platform that has
the many dimensions of intelligence
captured and decomposed in ways that can
be recomposed in multiple applications
in fact from the original system we have
now created dozens of different
components that are available on the
cloud as api's that the whole world can
build applications on top of and today
we have tens of thousands of application
developers or building applications in
every domain whether it's to shop to
travel to learn to discover to do
research to assist the blind and in
every industry that matters health care
financial services education resource
intensive industries like oil and gas
you name it our vision is that every
professional on the planet and that's a
couple of billion of us every
professional who is a knowledge worker
has a cognitive assistant like Watson to
help them do their daily tasks so what
we've done is defined a category of
systems we call them cognitive systems
which we'll learn continuously they will
reason with specific goals in mind and
they will interact with us humans
naturally this is just the beginning of
a journey
there's many breakthroughs that are yet
to be made I and my colleagues are
researching many technologies
that will help us get to better machine
learning and machine reasoning and
combinations of those many kinds of
specialized infrastructure it's not just
the normal von Neumann architectures
that we are all used to we will probably
need different kinds of architectures in
the future and also how to work with
people more effectively not just with an
individual but with groups of people and
do problem solving in a collaborative
manner call that collaborative cognition
let me get back to the idea of
professionals or knowledge workers as a
medical professional with a computer
cognitive assistant like the ones that
I've been talking about you can rethink
medical imaging or oncology or any one
of these fields that you're talking
about and these fields are already
getting a huge lift because of the of
the presence of cognitive assistants so
for example in oncology the demand for
oncologists is almost twice the supply
of oncologists the only way we can
address this is by putting cognitive
assistants in the hands of today's
oncologist and training new ones drug
discovery takes a really long time but
using cognitive systems it can be
shortened dramatically clinical trial
matching while there are lots of
clinical trials that are happening today
very few of them are able to actually
recruit patients and and even for those
it's very difficult for practitioners to
understand the outcomes let me show you
this exalter sonic image has arrived
tumor detection tumor has been found
perceived to tumor characterization
shape detection oval get clinical input
from a patient files
high fever master dhaniya tender left
breast level combined recommendation
differential diagnosis either simple
cysts or galactose EO patient management
favor course of antibiotics over fine
needle aspiration or incision and
drainage end of case processing as you
can see this is a cognitive assistant
that is providing information and
options for a radiologist this is a
decision support system it does not
replace the radiologist but it assists
them to be much more effective than they
are today as an environmental scientist
you can rethink many things about how we
manage our environment such as air
quality management or energy
optimization or even larger macro
activities like planning for cities just
this morning we announced something
called green horizons a program is
started in China where as you know there
are many environmental issues with
particles particulates and we have found
that with cognitive technologies we can
forecast much better
how renewable energy can be generated
and we think we're on track for reducing
the particulates by 30% by 2017 doing
this more globally if you're a
researcher as many of you are in this
audience you will be very interested in
this application where you ask the hard
questions and a computer like Watson can
come back with all of the claims it goes
through huge amounts of data from
corpses comes back with claims and
evidence both supporting or opposing
your claim you can do your research
reports much faster in minutes instead
of in days or weeks so what does it all
mean for the future of expertise as I
said before in the future experts will
work with cognitive assistants on a
routine basis with learning reasoning
machines and the average expert of
tomorrow will be much better than the
top experts of today
and I would say that most of us will be
as good as the best experts of tomorrow
so there's nothing to fear about this I
think we should need to understand more
so we can take the world to a better
place thank you very much thank you